I met postmasters personally to hear how
their lives their lives and the lives of
their families have been affected by
these events and every time I moved by
the impact that these events have had on
individual postmasters lives and their
fight for justice over a number of years
and I'd like to pay tribute to
colleagues on both sides of the house
for the uh for the way that they have
supported postmasters and their efforts
to expose the truth and see Justice Done
today I'd like to take the opportunity
to update the house and the latest steps
that the government is taking to ensure
that fair compensation is paid to people
impacted by the Scandal now as you all
know the members of the Glo performed a
great public service by bringing the
case in 2019 which exposed the Scandal
and that's why I was pleased with the
chancellor announced in March this year
that further funding is being made
available to ensure that they receive
similar levels of compensation to that
which is available to their non-glo
peers now today I can update the house
that the government intends to make an
interim payment of compensation to
eligible members of the Glo who are not
already covered by other compensation
support and that's totaling 19 and a
half million pounds together with the
share of the December 2019 settlement
that we understand was distributed to
the Glo postmasters this brings the
total of compensation to around 30
million pounds
postmasters will become contacted in the
coming weeks to submit an application
after which we aim to discrete the
distribute the funds within a few weeks
of receiving the application and I hope
that will go some way in helping many
postmasters who have and still are
facing hardships but in parallel we'll
continue to work at PACE on delivering
the final compensation scheme for the
Glo and I can confirm that we will be
appointing freeths to access the data
and methodology that they developed in
relation to the distribution of the 2019
settlement freeze represented the Glo
claimants and have vital knowledge and
expertise based on their involvement in
that case and this will allow us to work
at PACE on the design of a scheme of the
jfsa and Fritz to give those in the Glo
similar compensation to their non-glo
peers
as promised in March we will informally
consult with members of the Glo about
the proposed schemes operation and I'm
also pleased to announce that members of
the Glo group will be able to claim
reasonable legal fees as part of
participating in the compensation scheme
and I hope that will allay any concerns
that they may have about meeting the
costs of seeking legal advice and
support when applying to the scheme
turning now to progress on compensation
for overturned criminal convictions I'm
pleased to report to the house the
interim payments are progressing well as
of 29th of June there have been 75
overturned convictions with the most
recent convictions being Ableton just in
recent weeks and the post office has
received 74 applications for interim
payments including several new
applications recently
67 offers have been accepted by and paid
out to payments totally nearly seven
million pounds
this marks significant progress with 10
additional interim payments made to
postmasters since I updated the Bayes
select committee on the 11th of January
2022 and I'm pleased that these interim
payments have helped to deliver an early
down payment on the compensation due to
effective postmasters in advance of full
and final compensation packages being
agreed
now for those postmasters with an
overturned conviction who have already
submitted Quantified claims I can share
that we are working with post office to
agree part payment of agreed elements of
claims such as loss of earnings wherever
possible and will continue to do so with
additional claims when they're submitted
now taking this step should enable us to
avoid undue delays by awarding partial
compensation while the outstanding
matters are resolved
but I acknowledge that one area where
it's been challenging to agree
compensation is non-pecuniary Damages
some of which will reflect the wider
impact on postmaster's lives that these
wrongful convictions have had that
includes compensation for their loss of
Liberty or impacts on their Mental
Health
a number of the postmasters have agreed
to refer this issue to the process of
early Mutual evaluation to be conducted
by former Supreme Court Judge Lord Dyson
it's hoped that this evaluation will
facilitate the resolution of those
issues and we stand ready as Government
to support the delivery of the early
Mutual evaluation process and Keen to
ensure that the outcomes of this process
enable Swift compensation so I urge all
postmasters with a horizon related
conviction to continue to come forward
to seek to have these overturned they're
being contacted individually by the CCRC
and other relevant bodies to encourage
them to do so
in addition to the progress and
compensation for those with overturned
criminal convictions good progress has
been made on delivering compensation for
those in the historic shortfall scheme
as of 23rd of June 65 percent of
eligible claimants have now received an
offer meaning 29 million pounds has now
been offered and that 444 further
postmasters have been offered to
compensation since my last update to the
house and I'd like to thank the
independent panels for their diligent
work in progressing those cases
as I've said previously I've set the
post office the ambition to make a
hundred percent of HSS offers by the end
of the calendar year and the government
is working closely with post office to
achieve this but as I said before it's
important in addition to providing
compensation that we learn lessons so
that the something similar can never
happen again and that's why the
government set up the post office
Horizon I.T inquiry and put it on a
statutory footing to ensure that it has
all the powers that it needs to
investigate what happened establish the
facts and make recommendations for the
future so we're cooperating fully with
the inquiry to ensure that the facts of
what happened are established and
Lessons Learned